donc là évidemment j'ai pas mis ma
ceinture donc ça BIPE donc je vais
pouvoir gérer mon frein mon
accélération et ma direction sur le même
joystick un simulateur de conduite à
l'hôpital après 3 ans de développement
et de recherche cet appareil haut de
gamme est aujourd'hui présent dans de
nombreux hôpitaux comme celui de plaisir
il permet de révolutionner l'évaluation
des compétences des patients à la
conduite toute personne qui a une
réduction ou un impact sur sa santé que
ça soit moteur cognitif doit s'il
souhaite repasser ou du moins s'évaluer
à l'aptitude de la conduite soit c'est
des personnes qui ont déjà eu leur
permis et à ce momentl le permis est
invalidé S a une évolution il faut à ce
momentlà passer une réévaluation à la
conduite donc se faire évaluer par des
équipes pluridisciplinaires repasser
devant médecin agréé et ces équipes là
vont définir les adaptations nécessaires
au profil de la personne au handicap
pour après repasser quelques heures de
conduite et repasser son permis de
conduire ici le simulateur est proposé
au patients qui suivent un parcours de
soins de suite ou de rééducation
l'avantage de cet outil pouvoir
s'adapter à chaque pathologie le
simulateur permet en fait de faire la
passerelle euh entre les bilans papier
crayon qu'on effectue dans les centres
de rééducation euh que ça soit à tous
les à tous les niveaux au niveau
cognitif par les neuropsychologues au
niveau ergo par différents bilans de
détection ou par tous les bilans moteurs
et l'idée c'est d'avoir une passerelle
avec l'évaluation qu'on va faire en
situation écologique donc en véhicule
pour pouvoir avoir des données
objectives du patient euh sur ses
capacités à conduire en fonction des
différentes adaptations qu'on va vouloir
tester ou des différentes situations
qu'on va vouloir tester dans les
logiciels pour le réaliser plusieurs
années de travail ont été nécessaires
entre la Fondation Maïf pour la
recherche l'UVSQ et le centre de
ressources et d'innovation mobilité
handicap commercialisé depuis 2020 le
simulateur est déjà présent dans une
vingtaine de centres